the jurogan experience because
with covid there was a sense
there's this big bad thing from the
outside this virus that's coming to get
all of us
we didn't know a lot about the virus but
the more we find out
the more we adapt the more you would
think
that some of these intrusions
into our privacy into our liberty
that that would you know
it would stop and we would be able to be
free and in some countries
and even in some states here people are
still insisting
that the government has those powers the
government still has
control over my husband is from the uk
and i just asked you know
who has been to see your mother we call
her granny who has been to see
granny well
daughter and boyfriend but they were
sitting outside
why can't they sit inside and he says
the rules haven't changed yet but
there's something in me that asks myself
who's enforcing those rules
yeah and why in the age of testing
are those rules applicable why why when
you can find out if someone's negative
for the the virus
why can you keep them from them well the
fact so
why initially i think we were all in
agreement
it was to curtail yes the virus
but why the rules are still in place
when the threat is gone
that's a very good question well why
wouldn't we understand what the virus is
now
the rules were put in place when we
thought it was the black plague i mean
we thought it was going to be like the
spanish flu and
kill a vast majority or a large
percentage rather of the population
it's not it's not the same thing it's
still terrible
for the people that get it and die and
the people that have poor health and the
people that have
underlying conditions and comorbidities
but it's not what we thought it was
going to be
but we're still treating it like we
treated it a year ago
we're looking at it the same way we
looked at it in march of last year
i think what bothers me you're
absolutely right but what bothers me now
is that it's not even possible to have a
debate about that right
and that's so anytime people say you
should be suspicious of government don't
give government any powers because once
they have that power they won't give it
back
yes i think those people are being
vindicated in the sense that
and i would say in the past and of
course not if there's no need for
government to have that power they'll
give it back
but now this government wants to just
skip the power even though the threat is
gone
it's just human nature you know there
there's a tremendous drop in
cases in los angeles and yet you still
can't go to the gym you have to eat
outside and they just opened up eating
outside
two weeks ago yeah we we never
understood that because it doesn't
spread outside well it doesn't make
sense for
for a fact i know that they did it for
optics
because i know someone who works with
the government who literally had this
conversation
with someone saying why are we doing
this when there's no evidence whatsoever
that it spreads outside
and they said it's for optics so they're
closing businesses down and they're
denying people living
for optics but what they're doing is
they're using
power they have power and these are just
individuals or human beings and they're
subject to human nature
it's human nature to exercise power
you see that with bosses over employees
you see that in the stand for prison
experiments
you see it's just things that people do
you give people power
over people and they use it
but in this case when you say optics
what will they use that power
for then because the optics they will be
voted out of
power if they carry on like this i don't
know if they will
i don't know if they will because
there's so many people
that are so their
cursory understanding of human nature
and their
lack of real inquisition
the lack of real questioning of the
government's motives
and also this terrible fear
of the virus the terrible fear of what
it actually is
if you go to los angeles today and i
when i talk to my friends
they have a totally different idea of
what the virus is
than if you're here in texas it's one of
the things that i noticed immediately
once i came here it's one of the reasons
why i moved here
people like they treat it like it's a
bad cold
yeah which is what it is it kills people
but so does the flu
but we never close down schools for the
flu the flu actually kills kids
this this kills very few children with
a tiny tiny tiny tiny percentage my kids
both got it and they it was nothing it
was like a headache
was gone in a day this is what we're
seeing
with with human
nature when people have the ability to
tell people
you can't work that's very dangerous
or to tell someone your business is not
essential
but target is well maybe you have a
small store
that sells goods well you can't open but
this big store this big chain
why but they're they they're part of
special interest groups they contribute
to the politicians
you know there's unions that are
involved like that woman that we were
talking about before the show
who had a restaurant in los angeles and
she had outside dining that she paid she
paid
thousands of dollars that she probably
didn't even have
to set this up so she can keep her
business afloat and then they told her
you have to close down outdoor dining
and across the parking lot
the television and movie studios were
allowed
to have outdoor dining yeah like
literally she could walk 10 steps
and she could be in their outdoor dining
and her business is being forced to shut
down
it doesn't make any sense because it
doesn't have to because it's optics
they're just giving
the optics that they're doing something
the cases rise
because here's the thing about lockdowns
that have been pretty clearly
established
one of the things first of all they
don't work they don't really
curtail what they don't really curtail
the virus
but what they do do is they force people
inside when you force people inside and
you force people to congregate
it spreads easier it spreads and that's
part of the problem
it's it spreads easier inside than it
does yes
it doesn't there's no evidence no real
evidence that it does spread outside
yeah but it does spread inside and so
you force people inside you tell people
they can't work
and they're all congregated together
inside yes inside and
they're more fearful they're not getting
vitamin d they're not getting sun
they're not getting exercise
with more domestic violence yes and more
mental health issues more suicide
and all that stuff's through the roof
and more drug addictions and more drug
overdoses
and all those problems that
they don't get calculated in in the risk
assessment
when you're talking about the risk of
the virus there's a lot of other risks
there's a lot of other problems yeah and
the government doesn't give a [ __ ] about
that they
they keep getting paid no matter what
when they close down these businesses i
think the government i think the state
i think the the governor and i think the
the mayor
they should be paid proportionately with
the amount of money that's generated by
the businesses
particularly the businesses that are
forced to close you see how [ __ ]
quick
everything opens up it would open up
like that see how quick everything opens
up if you give people the freedom to go
places
you don't have to go to these
restaurants if you're worried about
catching covet
you don't have to go to the gym if
you're worried about catching it you can
stay home
you can social distance you can wear
masks you can exercise in the park
out in nature but you can't because the
park's shot because they're worried
about covet
like these are some of the rules that
people have had to deal with over this
past year
nonsensical rules like you can't go to
the park you got you can't go to the
beach
it's nonsense and everybody knows it's
nonsense and it's not science based
when they say follow the science well
you're not following the science
because if you did follow the science
you'd let people do anything they wanted
outside
because the science clearly shows it
doesn't spread outside well if you
follow the science you would say
let us have a debate and you would have
an open debate where you let both sides
speak out
yes what we are now seeing and it is
absolutely horrifying
is that you let one side decide that
speaking for lockdown
invoke science and say the sign says
lockdown
but there are other scientists who are
saying no not so fast
and those ones are not allowed to speak
i have a colleague
scott atlas at the hoover institution
and he's made a few points about
why some of the things that we're being
told to do are not actually supported by
signs but people like him can't get
their voices out because they're
demonized demonized shut out
kicked out of the whole debate
and and i think we can't go on like this
no no we can't and it's it's it's
forcing a massive divide
in our country and it's it's terrifying
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience